I've got some I've got some news for him  that's an advice for the right honorable  gentleman look behind you there  [Applause]  thank you Mr Speaker you helpfully  circulated a uh an update on the  behavior in this place now in the in the  this year when we've been celebrating a  hundred years of women getting the vote  do you think it's appropriate language  but can I ask my right on bull friend to  call people a stupid women in this  chamber  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  can I say to my honorable friend that I  think that everybody in this house  particularly in this 100th year  anniversary of women getting the vote  should be aiming to encourage women to  come into this chamber and  should and should therefore use  appropriate language in this chamber  when they are referring to female  members